that's right it's good
we met the last three northern white
rhinos in existence they have three
armed guards that follow them around and
make sure the poachers don't kill them
so they have to have 24-hour security
yes do you think people will come in
here to try to take their horn yeah as
we know that poaching is that still a
serious Talent Jota is very tricky it
might be able to manage commits from
anywhere so we need to be protecting all
the time there are many factors that are
causing the eradication of certain
animals but all of that gets exacerbated
by climate change he doesn't know that
he's the last of his kind but we do and
that's why I think the onus lies on us
what goes around comes around
as we disrupt and destroy the world the
consequences are very real I want the
world to know that time a change is
happening it's here and for us to be
able to do something about it we must
take responsibility it's not enough to
sort of like feel bad about it or feel
like oh I feel really emotional about
that or I feel really like sad that that
animal is going to become extinct I
think what we have to do is ask for
innovation around carbon emissions we
have to demand it what we do in terms of
our carbon emissions that affects our
future and the future of the animals
that roam these Plains